[Music]
on this tuesday night
demanding justice for jacob blake
the outrage in wisconsin over the police
shooting of a black man
they shoot first and then try to justify
it later
as the violence becomes a weapon in
america's presidential race
the calm before the storm where
hurricane laura is expected to lash out
pandemic road map for school buses the
bus at the best of times is a bit of a
cesspool
anxiety over what critics call a lack of
protection
and a disorienting orientation week this
year is going to be different for
everybody
canadian universities learn a new way to
welcome students
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
robin gill i shot my son
seven times seven
times
like he didn't matter but my son matters
good evening and thank you for joining
us you just heard the father of a 29
year old black man who is now paralyzed
after being shot in the back by police
the shooting in wisconsin was caught on
camera and has set off a wave of anger
in cities
across the united states at times it's
been fiery
the unrest in the city of kenosha where
jacob blake was shot
sunday evening has destroyed or damaged
dozens of businesses
blake's mother says her son would be
unpleased with violent demonstrations
she also called on protesters police and
politicians
to find unity and not resort to hate
do jacob
justice on this level and examine
your hearts
yes
we need healing
it's been a long summer with a spotlight
on racial injustice in america
and as eric sorensen reports this
incident sharpens the political divide
as the u.s presidential race heats up
a second night of unrest fires and
defiance of a curfew in the name of
jacob blake
and once more angry protests have spread
to other american cities
as they did after the death of george
floyd in a summer of increasing
awareness around the black lives matter
movement
another police incident has unnerved
many americans
it makes you scared i fear for myself i
fear from my
other black brothers and sisters the
circumstances aren't fully known but
there's evidence
jacob blake a black man was shot by
police multiple times in the back
my kids is in the car the description by
blake's fiancee
is gut-wrenching and saw that officer
grabbed jacob by his
t-shirt and turned his head and just off
as many times as he felt like it blake
is reportedly paralyzed from the waist
down though it's unclear if that's
permanent there have been no charges the
officers involved have been put on
administrative leave
blake's lawyer says the shooting is all
too familiar we keep saying this after
every tragedy we can't have a justice
system for black america and one for
white america
barely two months before the u.s
presidential election the protests are
reigniting the battle over public
perception around race and violence
democrats are urging peaceful protest
for george floyd last week at their
convention democrats pledged to address
race and justice we've got to do the
work
to fulfill that promise of equal justice
under law this week a very different
message at the republican national
convention
america is not a racist country
rioters must not be allowed to destroy
our cities
republicans are warning of a dark future
if joe biden is elected
even featuring the couple who brandished
weapons against black lives matter
protesters
your family will not be safe in the
radical democrats
america the unrest sparked by the
shooting is happening on president
donald trump's watch
democrats say trump has fanned the
flames of racial injustice
but scenes of violence also play to a
republican message
of fear in middle america eric sorensen
global
news toronto there's talk among the
toronto raptors of a potential playoff
boycott in the wake of the jacob lake
shooting
players say they're frustrated that
despite repeated calls for action
nothing seems to change you know coming
down here making a choice to play
um you know we're supposed to not be in
vain but
it's just starting to feel like
everything we're doing is
is just going through the motions and
nothing's really changing
i'm frustrated honestly
i'm disappointed i'm pretty tired and
sick to my stomach to have to sit up
here and talk about this again and
continue
this long fight that we've been fighting
[Music]
since day one you know of slavery
the raptors are supposed to start their
second round series against the boston
celtics
on thursday a warning today from
canada's top doctor about the rising
rates of coven 19
in young people teresa tam says young
canadians
can't afford to let their guard down
there have been more than 125 000 cases
of coven 19
in canada and more than 9 000 people
have died
tonight there are still more than 4 800
active cases of copa 19
across the country alarmingly people
under 40
make up nearly half of all new cases
recorded last week
and 20 to 29 year olds account for 25
of cases despite making up just 14
of the population and 30 to 39 year olds
are next accounting for 21 of new cases
last week the most concerning issue
is that as covert 19 continues to
circulate in any age group
as it has four weeks in young adults it
builds a reservoir of the virus
that can spill over affecting others
young
and old and quebec's premier won't force
quebecers to download the federal
government's coven 19
contact tracing app is designed to warn
canadians if they've come within two
meters of another user
who later tests positive for cova 19.
it's currently only being used in
ontario
the federal government wants other
provinces to follow suit to ensure
people
traveling between provinces are notified
of possible exposures
with students heading back to class
schools are switching lanes to try to
limit the spread of covet 19.
but there are concerns for those in the
driver's seat
they see a potential weak link in the
system the buses that carry children
to school mike armstrong explains
as a bus driver there are the problems
you can see and check for
that hasn't changed but rob robson's
been driving a bus for a decade and says
getting back behind the wheel this year
has him nervous covet 19 isn't something
you can see
i'm 60 years old so now technically i'm
you know in that high risk
category so i don't want to catch it
from anybody i don't want to give it to
anybody either
we need it to be safe now robson isn't
alone
the toronto bus drivers union says its
members still don't know enough about
safety protocols
it says while everyone's worried about
kids in classrooms not enough is being
done to mitigate risk in buses
a place where physical distancing ranges
from unlikely
to impossible that school bus
which wouldn't have the square footage
of one classroom
will carry 72 kids shoulder to shoulder
each province has different rules about
busing what's allowed and what isn't
what appears to be shared is concern
this was a recent protest about school
safety in alberta
i mean the bus at the best of times is a
bit of a cesspool
the directive from the ministry some of
the tightest
new rules are in quebec the government's
limiting buses to 48 students
they'll have assigned seating and masks
are mandatory
there's also a new job being added to
the driver's day
cleaning drivers with the company
transco are each being given a bag of
cleaning products
and ppe and in some cases plastic
barriers are being put in
now that's not something allowed under
transport canada rules in
other provinces there's a reason why a
school bus is 16 times safer than a car
that's because it's been tested over and
over again
to be the safest possible so you don't
make changes to it
no now some quebec schools did reopen
for several weeks at the end of the last
school year there was a chance to see
what worked and what didn't
transco says one of the things it found
was positive students were aware of the
virus
and cooperated well with drivers mike
armstrong global news montreal
canada and china held top level talks in
rome today
[Music]
canada's foreign affairs minister spoke
with his chinese counterpart about
collaborating in the search for a covid
vaccine francois philippe champagne also
reiterated demands that michael kovrick
and michael spavor be released
the two were detained after huawei cfo
mong wang zhou was arrested in vancouver
on behalf of the american government
erin ochoa faced the media for the first
time since becoming the conservative
party's new leader
let's bring in our david aiken and david
ernotol is trying to convince canadians
that he's like
no other conservative leader before him
well that's right rob
in fact o'toole said something today
that neither andrew scheer nor stephen
harper
ever said i won the leadership of the
conservative party
as a pro-choice conservative mp
one that that one with a strong mandate
o'toole also declared himself a defender
of lgbt
rights i am an mp with a clear track
record
on standing up for human rights whether
it's women whether it's the lgbt
community
o'toole felt compelled to make those
declarations for two reasons
first
he won his party's leadership when at
least 20 thousand voters
who had initially supported one of the
two social conservatives running against
him
swung their support over to o'toole on
the final ballot
and he's being challenged by liberal mps
over the continued presence in the tory
caucus
of ontario mp and leadership rival derek
sloan
sloan has come under fire for his
crudely articulated anti-abortion views
and for the way he criticized chief
public health officer dr teresa tam
o'toole also named key staff positions
tuesday and
those staffers are like o'toole himself
all
from eastern canada that's a clear sign
that the locus of power in the
conservative party has shifted
for the first time in the history of the
modern party from the west
to the east now that said o'toole's
first phone calls
were to the premiers of alberta in
saskatchewan and
western alienation was the very first
item o'toole brought up
when he talked monday to prime minister
justin trudeau
if they continue to leave out the
ability for our resource sector to get
canadian resources to market we're going
to see more
western alienation we're going to see
less
jobs and opportunity for canadians in
ontario in atlantic canada
o2 will also caution the pm against any
parliamentary funny business
if mr trudeau thinks he can play some
games with a new leader and force an
election we will be ready
next up for o'toole a face-to-face
meeting with quebec's premier
and the first meeting with his caucus
robin
david aiken in ottawa thanks david in
the u.s the first night of the
republican convention
painted a rosy picture of the country's
future if donald trump is re-elected
as jackson proskow reports that could
spell trouble for other republicans
on november's ballot
on a night filled with unquestioning
praise for donald trump
trump is the bodyguard of western
civilization there were rosy promises of
better days
we must fight to save america now or we
may lose her forever
and dire claims about the end of days if
joe biden is elected
they want to enslave you to the weak
dependent
liberal victim ideology to the point
that you will not
recognize this country or yourself as
republicans rally around the president
they've ignored the more than 175
thousand lives lost to the covet 19
pandemic
and made no mention of the millions of
americans who are now unemployed
all on trump's watch i do think that the
devotion you hear
from republican office holders toward
trump um
it's it's unusually folsom praise for
for the for the president instead the
party has gone all in
insisting a silent majority is on their
side
it's a perilous strategy trump's
personal approval rating sits at just 42
percent
while only 13 percent of americans are
satisfied with the way things are going
in their country
it's pretty risky given that the
president is behind right now and
um if the president goes down to defeat
um
he could drag down a lot of members of
his own party with him
it's clear trump isn't interested in
winning over new voters
he simply wants to keep his base
agitated he'll need them to vote
and to back him if he contests the
election results
the only way they can take this election
away from us
is if this is a rigged election
the convention has made it clear this is
trump's show
republicans are simply part of it
political speeches from the white house
grounds will further blur the lines
between
politics and governance this week while
trump will feature prominently
every single night jackson proskow
global news
washington as one storm vanishes
another is on the horizon coming up the
hurricane hurtling toward
the u.s gulf coast
marco came ashore as a weak tropical
storm but now people living along the
u.s gulf coast are preparing for
hurricane laura
that storm is expected to hit later this
week
laura has already dredged cuba and the
island of hispanola where at least 23
people died as a result of heavy
flooding
and landslides global news meteorologist
ross hull is tracking laura as it moves
into the gulf of mexico and that's where
it's expected to strengthen ross
robin laura is expected to become the
first major hurricane of the atlantic
hurricane season so far
why the right ingredients are in place
the warm waters of the gulf of mexico
bathtub temperature in many areas over
30 degrees
and something called vertical wind shear
there isn't a lot of it from top to
bottom in the atmosphere which will
allow this system
to intensify as we take a look at the
satellite image the storm isn't as
ragged as it was earlier on about 24
hours ago even it's starting to take on
more of a defined
shape that eyewall feature is also
starting to develop
and that's the sign of a healthy storm
in terms of the track
well as it moves across the gulf of
mexico absorbing that warm water
late wednesday into thursday likely
reaching major hurricane status
southeastern portions of texas
stretching east
towards the mouth of the mississippi
river all in line for very strong winds
storm surge and also heavy rain so this
is certainly a storm to watch
it will likely get absorbed into the
westerlies the remnants of the storm and
could provide some rain for eastern
canada
by the weekend we'll keep an eye on this
one robin all right thanks for that ross
still ahead did a canadian company's
fall give rise to a chinese tech giant
before chinese company huawei became the
largest telecommunications equipment
manufacturer
in the world a canadian company nortel
was on top with 70 percent of all
internet traffic running on canadian
technology
tonight global news has deeper insight
into what led to the collapse of nortel
and how china may have been involved a
former nurtale security adviser claims
the chinese government was behind a
systemic hack at nortel
that began in 2004 and went on for a
decade
you know they were still on our network
they were still stealing and they got
away with it this was like
precision work like a military unit for
goodness sake
these guys were highly trained and they
beat our best people that we had and our
best tools and systems that we had and
they totally took us down they had
access to everything
brian shields believes the chinese
government used information from nortel
to facilitate the rise of huawei
nortel's fall centered around an
accounting scandal some top
executives were charged but were later
acquitted
but it happened as huawei gained market
dominance and shield says that's more
than a coincidence
huawei and the chinese government deny
stealing
nortel's property let's bring in global
investigative reporter sam
cooper now who's been digging into all
of this and sam brian shields says
he's disappointed ottawa didn't step in
to protect nortel what does he think the
government
should have done
that's right shields and others say
china focused all its cyber war power
against nortel because nortel's
innovation secrets
were so key to china's
telecommunications future
and the rcmp did investigate the nortel
hacking complaint in 2004
but experts told us the rcmp did not
then and
still does not have the jurisdiction or
the resources
to fight state-sponsored cybercrime
against canada's industries
and furthermore canada doesn't have
tough foreign interference laws
like australia or other countries that
can fight back against china's very
broad
espionage and interference networks
so what are some of these broad
interference techniques that china uses
sources told us in the nortel case and
generally there's a really shocking
convergence between chinese intelligence
and chinese organized crime that's
involved in stealing
canadian intellectual property and even
attempts to influence canadian political
and business leaders
so for example sources say organized
crime cyber hackers in china will be
given
immunity if they provide valuable
properties such as
covid19 vaccine research or nortel's
secrets
to chinese intelligence another example
could be that
gangsters connected to real estate
development in canada
could be facilitating visits to china
between
canadian leaders and chinese leaders
china did not respond to any of our
detailed questions in this story
sam cooper in ottawa thanks sam and you
can have a longer read of sam's deep
dive into the nortel hack
on our website globalnews.ca global
national
up next campus conundrum how do you
welcome first-year students
with no festivities
the first cohort to graduate from high
school during this pandemic is now
seeing another rite of passage
blocked frosh orientation week of
welcome
no matter the name the first year
experience has gone virtual for
post-secondary students in canada
jordan armstrong looks at how campuses
are transitioning
to keep up tradition
frosh week is the introduction to
university life for first-year students
there's a lot of partying drinking
bonding
and at queen's university in kingston
ontario a lot of body paint just getting
ready for the frosh to come in
at least there used to be this year
canadian campuses are nearly deserted
and like everything else frosh week will
have a different feel
rather than just kind of copy and paste
in our events from in person
to an online set in we wanted to be
mindful of
the different you know platforms and
technology we have available to us
and really mold our events around that
to engage
students as much as possible at ryerson
university in toronto
orientation week leaders have tried to
create virtual events
which are also interactive and that
includes the campus tour
the student campus center has you
covered we're hosting some smaller
kind of interview type concerts with
some local gta artists so
really give the students the opportunity
to interact and engage with
artists who they might not be able to in
a traditional year where they're just at
a concert
at the university of british columbia in
vancouver they're still working out the
details on how frosh week will look this
year is going to be different for
everybody
it's different for our faculty it's
different for our students and it's
different for our staff
with a majority of ubc classes moved
online
it's expected university dorms will be
quieter than normal
still campus security will be ready to
deal with scofflaw partiers
who flout physical distancing perhaps a
sign of the changing times
there are still plenty of those little
red beer cups
left on the grocery store shelf jordan
armstrong global news
vancouver and that is global national
for this tuesday i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is this flock of
birds flying over conception bay north
in newfoundland and labrador thank you
for watching and i'll see you back here
tomorrow
have a great night
[Music]
you